hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar tools to empower your NK cell
research i am michelle action of
leopards and I'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by Melanie biotech to learn more
about our sponsors
please visit www.gfi.com/webmonitor in
the presentation to do so simply type
them into the ask the question box and
click send if you have trouble hearing
or seeing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credit tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits I now present today's
speakers Martha lemon Oh the product
manager of research and clinical end K
sell products and milkweed biotech for a
complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen Martha you may now
begin your presentation
welcome everyone thank you so much for
the introduction I would like first of
all to thank you for attending this
webinar
my name is Martha Lou Ivana and today I
want to share with you how to drive your
NK cell research further whether you're
doing basic or translational research I
am sure that you will benefit from this
webinar so let's start first this is
just an important disclaimer that is
phase that unless otherwise specifically
indicated Metheny biotech products and
services are for research use only and
not for therapeutic or diagnostic use so
just please acknowledge
so today we will navigate the different
technologies needed for a successful NK
cell research from cell separation to
set analysis and go and beyond to
translation of all your findings
let's start with a brief introduction I
would like to just highlight that
mentally biotech has been a key player
in the field of immunology for now
thirty years our products have been
published in more than 20,000 scientific
papers and we have invested a lot in R&D
and have enabled cell therapy procedures
all around the world
now let's get into the NK cell my
favorite immune cell type they play a
very important and key role to fight
tumors and virally infected cells they
are able to kill a variety of targets
through a contact dependent non-polluted
process that does not require prior
sensitization to an antigen and this is
what makes NK cells really useful and
wonderful this part of knows and
situation to an antigen and how are they
able to kill the target cells NK cells
are able to use different mechanisms
including direct losses of target cells
via perforin and granzymes beads also by
secreting different cytokines for
example interferon gamma and tumor
necrosis alpha or by inducing apoptosis
using fast ligand or trail in addition
NK cells are able to recognize
antibodies that are already bound to
target cells in a mechanism called
antibody dependent cell-mediated
cytotoxicity and this mechanism is used
by a variety of monoclonal therapeutic
antibodies that are already in the
market
so how can we exploit NK cells in
immunotherapy well angle cells can be
obtained from healthy individuals they
can be isolated expanded and infused
into patients suffering a wide variety
of diseases that are now under
investigation
moreover with the promising results of
car T cells NK cells can also be
genetically modified offering several
advantages compared to the T cells first
of all you can observe here that you can
use allergenic NK cells from a healthy
donor and this is one of the main
advantages however there are also more
including better killing or also use in
all the different mechanisms of killing
that I explained to you before but let's
now dive into another section of how
you're going to study your NK cells and
the first part of course will be to
isolate your NK cells this is the first
step that you will have to encounter
when you're studying your NK cells
so I would like to have this life here
because we get a lot of questions
regarding what is the benefit of the
column based technology in comparison to
our column free system so I will spend
some time here because I think it's
important for you to also have it in
mind the magnetic separations in column
base and columns free system have in
general a very comparable magnetic force
however the difference between the two
system is of course the column the
column are filled with little iron
spheres in these islands fears they pass
through a magnetic force on the next
over a very small distance amplifying
the magnetic force about ten thousand
volts and ensuring that the magnetic
field is constant throughout the column
does minimal level is of cells which is
none of it is sufficient to retain any
target cell that you label if you look
at the picture on the right hand side
you see a comparison of a cell
labeled with bigger bead using a column
free system the left and our tiny micro
beads on the right and you can also see
in the electron microscopy pictures in
the bottom that the bigger left is stick
to the surface of a cell in this case is
a T cell in this could lead to
activation and alteration of the cell
characteristics moreover in a column
based system this cell can run freely
throughout the column and can be washed
thoroughly to remove the average and
also contaminants
finally you can always take the
advantage of thinking translational
because these microbeads have also been
used all over the world in clinical
trials
the word options do you have to study an
isolate NK cells on the one side I will
just give you an overview the
traditional approach you will go from
your blood sample to produce PBMCs V
identity greatest interrogation NK cells
n can be isolated using max microwave
there will be a positive selection or
max isolation kit there will be negative
isolation meaning that you remove every
single cell that you are not interested
and leave your target cell on touch
next you can also have straight from
technology in this case instead of doing
the density centrifugation you can use a
new straight from technology NK and NKT
cells can be directly isolated from
different blood products and fastened
it's the way without the PV MC isolation
step in this case we are using CD 56
micro beads also if you're looking for
an untouched solution from blood you can
use Mac's Express and NK cells will be
untouched I just want to highlight some
of the kids that we have if you're not
familiar with them we have available
30:56 micro grid and also our
new-release
cv 56 micro grid in case of isolation
kids are touch cells we have a couple of
kids but the most useful one is the NK
cell isolation kit and here I just want
to give you a little sample of what does
it look like using the rear leaves this
is a new product that we chose have an
release that year and in this case from
TV mcs you can use a positive isolation
30:56 and then if you want to you can
get rid of the microbeads and also the
antibody attached to the cell that means
that you can use a cell for another
magnetic separation and what is
important here because I have heard a
lot of yes fears regarding using
positive isolation you don't have to
worry about cell activation you can see
in the graph before separation of the
PBMCs the activation markers on the
lower row 369 and 325 and you can see
that there is a very little amount of
percentage activated cells after
enrichment using the CD 56 microbeads
this percentage does not change too much
and after the feeding the cd3 cells also
you get to the very pure NK cell product
activation so this is a really great
tool especially if you want to
subsequently label for other type of
cell for example and nkg to see positive
cells or key to be a positive cells
the second option of course you can
start from different blood products and
skip the density greatest steps and for
that you can use either whole blood or
both occult or LLC and they all have
different amount of erythrocytes and of
course PMC and we have developed a
specific straight from microbeads for
each of these products
in this case I show you here just an
example of what traditionally you are
doing so I don't go into detail you are
probably very familiar with it once you
get your sample you have to do your
gradient density your centrifugation
your PBMC washes your counting and then
you start your isolation but comparison
to that if you use are straight from
technology you can easily start without
even counting cells with your baka code
for example you are two microwaves you
incubate 15 minutes and with the
multi-max 24 you can easily get in less
than 5 minutes all yourself most
importantly you have high recovery good
results and not cell activation and here
in this slide I would like to show you
how does it look like if you're used in
our city 56 microwaves because there are
no washes involved you have a really
great recovery and really nice purity
just remember that whenever you're using
city 56 microwave you will have a mixed
population of NK + NK t cell as you can
see in the plot on the bottom right
okay now let's continue to the other
great challenge of culturing and case
in the workflow I will show you just as
an example I have written down here step
by step generation of KY and K cells but
this workflow can be used with or
without the cards so in general if you
are going to culture NK cells this is
information very useful for you I
believe that you are probably very
familiar with these statements when you
try to expand NK cells they really don't
like it because they easily get
exhausted in most of the time you will
find that increased sales do not retain
their cytotoxic Isis attack acidity
activity after expansion and this is a
problem especially when you are studying
the NK cell functionality so what we
have developed for these reasons is a
specific NK media this media has proven
to have superior expansion and I will
show you in the next slide it's free of
any animal derived components it really
limits the growth of unwanted cells like
B cells or T or T cells and most
importantly it is available up to max
GMP quality so let's look at the data
let's say that you start with NK cells
isolated NK cells and you want to expand
them if you are using our media you can
get up to 5 times more in K cells
compared to our piece of media the text
max or other competitors that are really
not NK media they are mainly formulated
for other type of cells like a stem cell
so this is a really nice data and a half
key that I have because I have received
a lot of feedback from customers saying
that they get also very similar results
in the next slide if you are not
starting with isolated NK cells but with
P VMC's even starting with this
population you will find on the left
side that you get around three times
more NK cells contrary to other media
and the most important thing is if you
are used in our media the majority of
the
cells at the end will be NK cell in the
graphs on the right you can see that
around 65 to 75% of the cells are NK
cells when is in our media compared to
35 to 40 if you are using other medium
this is a protocol using interleukin 2
if you combine interleukin 2 plus
interleukin 15 you actually get higher
rate and more NK cells
so in reality what is very advantageous
from these media is that you can do
everything all your experiments in small
scale in research grade so anka marks
medium research grade and when you find
the optimal protocol if you need to
translate this to the clinic it's so
much easier because we have available
the GMP medium that has exactly the same
formulation at the research version and
here I show you some data if you're
comparing a research version energy MP
on the left side you find very similar a
full expansions and the most important
thing that I mentioned in the beginning
NK cells preserve digital toxicity
activity after expansion so after 14
days of expansion we tested the cells
against cell line k562 this is a
standard for our killing estates and you
can see that the killing was absolutely
preserved and it goes for both with the
research and also for the GMP medium
so of course the medium is very
important for your experiment but also
you will find out that you need to have
good cytokine one of the biggest issues
using the cytokines is this variability
between different lot and to overcome
this you could in theory perform this
load to load testing but why should you
do that in with your time and money and
something that we have done for you
so with our premium cytokine you can
relied a lot on the lot of specific
activity value but that we provide you
in a certificate of analysis using the
cytokines you do not need to do any pre
testing which will save a lot of time
and money and you can apply the same
amount of active site you can in each in
every experiment for maximum
reproducibility so this human grade
cytokine share the same characteristics
as they max GMP cytokines like the low
end or toxin content high purity and
they will be very relevant for your
preclinical studies again there are also
in GMP quality so your translation will
be really fast and easy
so of course if you're going to or
thinking about car in case sales you
might wonder what tools do we have to
help you will increase sales are
definitely a difficult sell type to
transduce normally it's very often that
the transaction is inefficient and you
require the use of something to enhance
this transaction we have the very
effective is in one this is our
transaction enhancer any worse developed
to enhance bio transaction of sales
growing in suspension like T cells or NK
cell chemically it is a fully synthetic
sortable captive that is non-toxic
enabling these higher transduction
levels with lower amounts of retro viral
or lentivirus vector it is very easy to
use you just premix your virus with the
vector of you seen in give it 10 minutes
and then just add to the mixture of your
NK cell the most important thing here
also you can have this reagent in GMP
quality when you translate this into
your large scale manufacturing
if you want to see some data here is
some so these are primary car and case
cells and the left side you will see not
just two then only the vector around 70%
of the face efficacy and if you use
vector fizzing then this enhancement is
up to 85% so this could be really
valuable in your research I want to show
you some data from customers so this
enhancement of the transaction efficacy
depends of course on your virus but
definitely if you have used in our media
and our vector P scene you have more
chances of getting more car NK cells
this is customer data so they try their
own system for their own media with
return acting and I gave them some
samples of vector P Cinemax median on
the left side and you can find that the
NK cells using our media were growing
even more so around 60 fold expansion at
16 million compared to the competitor
which was around half of them so in this
case vector P sync have the same
transaction rate around 50 percent but
at the end you will have double the
amount of car NK cells if a user system
again I think you have to just test it
and you will depend on your virus and
your protocol but I am almost sure you
would be a benefit
now let's go to the part of cell
analysis this part of the workflow must
be the most important because you had
invested so much time in so much work
and you need to make sure that your
analysis are right so let's start here
if you know something about Matheny
biotech is probably cell separation but
I just want to show you that we have so
many tools for your flow analysis we
really offer a comprehensive product
solutions for these flow analysis not
only from antibodies and dyes but we
also have ready to use keys and necess
so you can measure all of your samples
and get the best data from it if you're
not familiar with our recombinant
antibodies I just explained to you
really quick if you are trying to do
this in process control or quality
control or even your study your NK cells
or RIA finiti antibodies are practical
for you they are recommend Lea generated
and ensures very high purity and very
high load to load consistency for
greater reproducibility and all the
different antibodies have the same
Universal igg1 isotype that leads to the
fact that you only need one isotype
control that would save you some effort
and cost and also the complexity of your
experiment planning and last but not
least that we have the reality bodies
are characterized by a mutated FC region
that means that you can eliminate the FC
receptor blocking step there will be no
on a specific binding if you want to
know more about our great communal
antibodies please have a look in a web
page we have a webinar giving you all
the information that you need okay now
you know that we have our antibodies but
you're also wondering how can you study
your NK cells in terms of functionality
using cell analysis so we have here just
an example of two different assays the
first one is cytokine secretion assay
and another one is a standard killing
assay both of them can be performed in
using flow cytometry and I will show you
how probably you will think of cytokine
secretion let's say more like and Eliza
or something that does not require flow
but I want to show you a very nice tool
on how to analyze all of these cytokines
at once
so this is our actually multiplex or Max
leg cytokine kit would you see in the
pictures on microwaves which have bound
aunty inter looking so different of
those molecules that were love them when
the cells are able to secrete their
capture and then we have another
antibody with a different color that
will detect it so in this case from one
sample one supernatant you can analyze
well of those different cytokines over
factors or molecules and I want to show
you an example using the mug flicks
cytotoxic t + NK t cells so in this case
here you can find out that if you
incubate your NK cells with a target
cells NK cells will release some of
cytokine the 12 the ones that you can be
detecting using this kid I listed on the
left side so it includes interleukin 2
and most important I grant them be
interfering for in case them and with
one sample again you can measure all of
these and you don't have to worry you
can just collect your samples your
supernatant freeze them and once you
have enough sample you run it and you
get all the information ready for you
okay so once you have determined how
many or how much cytokines you have you
also want to know if your in case those
are able to kill so what we do here this
is just an example we have labeled our
target cells with a dye and in this case
we use a cell trace and you can see that
you can count yourself when you die them
and you just run a normal box plot
if you incubate either with natural
killer cells that are not reduced or
with car NK cells you will observe that
a different effector to target ratios
the NK cells will kill the target cells
and you can quantify these by looking at
the facts plot the left count the length
of this target cells remaining in your
sample so for example in the effective
target ratio five to one you have a
couple of cells remaining so NK cells
are able to kill but if you use car NK
cells that almost eliminate all of the
target cell
if you want to know more about the
protocol regarding these car engage
sales I'd invite you to download our
publication is open access so it's free
for you to use in which we have there
step by step how to generate car in case
sales using all of the tools and regions
that I just show you
moreover if you are interested in how to
cultivate in cases or how to do
phenotypic analysis you can always go to
our application tab for NK cell there's
a lot of protocols there you can
download them and you would also have
this downloadable protocol with a
timeline the products and tips and also
some data
so now let's go to the last part very
briefly I just want to encourage you to
always sing translation er so I'll show
you already all the tools that you can
have to study in K cells on your
research fitting so you can have from
sample preparation to cell isolation
cytokines medium and recombinant
antibodies but if you want to take this
to the next level we also have all the
tools that you need to actually study
clinical or to do the practical clinical
application of NK cell I'm not going
into too much details but I do want to
introduce your pal or platform for this
this is the clean Emacs prodigy is an
automated cell processing system for GMP
compliant cell manufacturing it allows
you to not only isolate cells but the
culture or to do transduction and you
can start from the beginning using one
single tool instead there is only one
use in a closed system with a interface
that allows you to programmer to do
different things for the NK cells were
working on this and we have two
different processes one of them is to
isolate NK cell the one on the Left cd32
b56 system and the other one we are
working on them is a natural killer cell
engineering system in this both of them
it will allow you to start with
leukapheresis products isolate NK cells
and have your final NK cells in your
infusion solution for example for
infusion to a patient or in the case of
the natural killer cell engineering it
will allow you to automatically
isolating k cells do the transduction
and expansion in one instrument this is
one only one system is closed system and
then you will have at the end of 14 days
your NK soon
so okay I'm getting to the end line in
general I would just like to summarize
by encourage you again to think
translational right from the start all
the reagents protocols or the support
throughout the whole NK or kyon case a
workflow you have seen today and they're
available to you we also have all these
in life GMP quality for seamless
transition from bench to the website and
once you discover the perfect protocol
of course you can always translate into
cleaning max prodigy platform which
allows standardize and transfer tables
and a scaleable of tension of n K sub
products so again choose Milton e
biotech as your partner in KY and K cell
manufacturing or in case of
manufacturing and if you are interested
in their getting to know more make sure
your visit our applications tab on NK
cells you will also find more webinars
application notes workflow protocols
scientific posters we're happy to share
everything that we have with you and
with this this is my last night I would
like to thank you very much for your
attention and for coming today
Thank You Martha for your presentation a
quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them
into the drop down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
labeled ask a question and click on the
send button Martha will answer as many
questions as time permits alright our
first question is will I have a problem
if I use CD 56 microbeads and I want to
perform a BCC a face
nice to hear that question I think I
have it very often and I am happy to say
that I we actually have they're showing
that using CD 56 microbeads of course
you will enrich NK and NKT cells but we
have to remember that this ad si si si
is based on the expression of CD 16 and
because NKT cells express very little
almost no CD 16 they will not interfere
with your ABC si si so you can be very
confident of using all of the strip from
products to the 56 micro grid and reach
your NK and NKT and perform your ABC C
without a problem
thank you I'll write your next question
what are the different formulations and
formats of MK max medium
yes so for the increments medium were
actually really proud of this media arm
it performs really really nice we have
now a research version so it's a bottle
of 500ml but we have also the GMP grade
for all the translational applications
and clinical manufacturing for example
on the clean Emacs prodigy and this GMP
version is available in a two little
flexible bags and the key thing is that
it has the same formulation of the
research version so when I tell you that
is truly translational it is truly
translational whatever you do on your
research lab can be translated into your
clinical protocol
now does the NK max medium contain
activating reagents for cytokines
no actually in Dorset these are Inca max
medium itself is chemically defined does
not contain any protein no human serum
albumin not insulin not cytokines with
this so that each researcher can
customize them beside cocktail or
cytokines you know now there are a
couple of different protocols you can
create memory like NK cells you can
create a mature NK cells so it all
depends on the site to concern you put
so we do not have any cytokine inside
the media you are free to choose
whatever your cocktail you want to
choose
now which cytokines people recommend for
the expansion of NK cells
so for the expansion of NK cells we
started actually with a protocol using
own interleukin 2 but a couple of
publications have shown that the
addition of interleukin 15 is actually
really good so our normal protocol
includes interleukin 2 and 15 so we
recommend that this protocol you can
download it in our webpage actually step
by step and it tells you with how many
cells we start when do we change the
media and you will get the results that
we have also have you seen in the graphs
today but also of course you can use
others like interleukin 12 of 18 many
other researchers are using these to
create like memory like NK cells and one
thing that I just want to highlight is
that you make sure that you use the
premium-grade cytokines to make sure
that you use the right dose and of
course you have the best reproduce
ability later
thank you looks like we have time for
one more question can you share the
protocol for car and K cell generation
yes we will have it available in a
webpage and right now it is not but I am
sure by the end of 2019 it will be there
so you just make sure that you go to a
website and you will be of data there we
have an application tab with the NK
cells you just go there and you will
probably find it
once again thank Martha for her time
today and how important research I'd
also like to thank the audience for
joining us and further interesting
questions any questions we did not have
time for today or those submitted during
the on-demand period will be addressed
by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration we would also like to thank
lab roots and our sponsor milky biotech
for underwriting today's educational
webcast this webcast can be viewed on
demand lab routes will alert you when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event until next time goodbye